it's story time
settle back and i'll begin
once upon a time
a mother duck sat patiently on her nest
of eggs waiting for them to hatch
and then one day she felt something move
beneath her
crack crack
filled with happiness she watched has
her eggs hatched one by one
i don't know about you but when i was
little story time was always one of my
favorite parts of the day
and i loved reading to my two sons when
they were small too
it's that special time when a parent and
child can be totally absorbed together
in mystical kingdoms fantastical
beasties or scruffy little ducks that
turn out to be swans
well that's how it is for some children
but for other children
there isn't a parent around to read to
them
i'd like to tell you about sophie
sophie's five years old and lives with
her parents
one day there's a bang at the door
sophie hears lots of shouting her mum's
crying
she sees the police dragging her father
away
sophie's afraid she starts crying too
weeks go by sophie doesn't know what's
happened to her dad
when she asks her mum her mum gets upset
so she stops asking
sophie waits
she really misses her dad
every day she hurries home from school
in case he's come back
on many nights she cries herself to
sleep
children at school start to tease her
they call her names
somebody's mum has heard that sophie's
dad is in prison
sophie pretends to be ill so she doesn't
have to go to school
and her teacher can't understand why
she's so far behind with her schoolwork
after what seems a long long time to
sophie
a letter arrives it's from her dad the
writing is very messy the letter makes
her mum cry
but she reads a little out to sophie
he says that he's okay and that he's
missing them
it's a short letter
sophie says she'd like to go and see her
dad wherever he is but her mum says
it's too far away and they can't afford
the journey
then one day the phone rings
sophie
come and speak to daddy
that sounds different
far away
he says he can't talk for very long and
anyway it's very noisy wherever he is
and sophie
doesn't know what to say to him
well as stories go that's not a very
nice one in the united kingdom
hundred thousand children
experience the shame and isolation of a
parent in prison
two hundred thousand that's more than
the number of children each year who are
affected by their parents divorcing and
it can affect the children of prisoners
very deeply
there can be problems at school and
they're three times more likely to
suffer from mental health issues
in so many ways children are the
unintended victims of their parents
crimes
in so many ways
children are the overlooked victims of
their parents crimes
until last november i was a serving
prisoner imprisoned for fraud
i was dishonest and i paid the penalty
before that i'd been a practicing
solicitor for 30 years
i'd had a happy and stable upbringing
a good education a happy marriage which
i'm pleased to say continues i have two
adult sons
when they were growing up i did my best
to be around for them
as much as i could and i took a careful
interest in what they did i read to my
boys every night
and ironically our favorite story was
burglar bill
but when i got to prison it soon became
apparent that my background was very
different to that of most other
prisoners
few of the men that i met had had a
decent education indeed many associated
education with humiliation and failure i
can tell you firsthand that prison is
dehumanizing
prisoners hard enough they shut down
they close in
just to survive
and this can be devastating for families
in fact maintaining contact with your
family from prison can be very difficult
indeed
and if a child does get to see their
parents in prison
they have to go through the same pat
down searches as the adults they walk
through the same detector frames they're
sniffed by the same sniffer dogs but all
because some children have been the
unwitting carriers of drugs and mobile
phones
and when they get through to see their
parent they may be tired from a long
journey
shy tongue-tied even upset
and it isn't easy for the parents who
may not be getting along
for many reasons not just these
over half of prisoners lose contact with
their children and families
how can we help prisoners to stay in
contact with their families
when i was a prisoner at channing's wood
prison i began working for a charity
called storybook dance
storybook dance began in 2003 when
sharon berry a civilian worker in a
prison realized just how much many
prisoners wanted to stay in contact with
their children
and so armed with a few story books
she began to help prisoners to read and
record stories to send home to their
children
it wasn't a new idea few ideas like this
are new
they're great ideas
but it was an instant success
you may wonder how does the recording
of the stories work in prison
is it difficult for prisoners
can it be challenging
well the process of choosing
reading and recording the story
can be very challenging for prisoners
prison is tough
and prisoners can't afford to show any
signs of weakness or vulnerability
but this this recording process
this can be
uncomfortable upsetting sometimes all
just a bit too much
and prisoners often cry
they cry because they regret missing out
on their children's lives
they cry because they're ashamed that
they've let their families down
they cry because they don't know how to
go about reading to their children
but because when they come to us
we offer a private space one-to-one
prisoners don't need to be tough anymore
and they can use their vulnerability as
a strength
when contacting with their children
i remember one prisoner who came to
record
he was a big hard man with a reputation
for being tough
he came along as implacable as ever but
when the door of the recording room
closed behind him that facade began to
crumble
from his pocket he took a screwed-up
piece of paper and quietly began to read
the words which he'd written
as a message for his two little ones
his hands were shaking
and then in a surprisingly quiet voice
he began to sing their favorite lullaby
you see there wasn't much that he could
do from behind bars to show his children
that he missed and loved them
but he could do this
once the recording is made
it's sent to the
storybook dance production unit at
channingswood prison
in devon
and that's where i worked
i was trained along with other prisoners
to edit and produce recordings sent in
from prisons all over the united kingdom
using audio and video software
the recordings
have the mistakes taken out
and
sound effects and music added in
the experience and skill which the
prison editors gain
helps them in their future employment
once the recording is finalized it's
transferred to a cd or a dvd
and sent out to the families so that the
children can watch them whenever they
feel the need
and they listen to these recordings and
watch them
a lot
at bedtime
in the car
some even take them to school to show
their friends
these recordings they show the children
that they're loved and missed
and they show the prisoner
that they can do something for their
child as a parent
how do you remember sophie
well one day just before christmas
a parcel arrived
and this is what was in it
let's listen to a little of it together
[Music]
higher and higher they flew
across land across oceans they spared
through the magical northern lights they
passed
i'd love to see
[Music]
they visited all the children in the
world and left presents for each and
every one
in the blink of an eye they were back in
front of the bottom field
[Music]
sophie and her mum listened to that
three times and they haven't laughed so
much in a long time
they can see that he's all right they
can see that he loves them and the next
time he rings
sophie's got plenty to talk about what
does charlie the champion
will daddy do another story very soon
since it began in 2003 storybook dance
has grown and grown
it now operates as storybook dance and
storybook mums in more than a hundred
prisons in the united kingdom
of the prisoners who take part say that
it's improved their relationship with
their child
and since
2003 over 60 000 dvds and cds have been
sent out to the children of prisoners
for sophie's family and for thousands of
families like them storybook dance has
been a lifeline
some prisoners say that it's the first
time that they've begun to build a
relationship with their child
and some poor readers have been so
inspired by what they've been able to
achieve that they've gone to education
classes to improve their own reading
skills
let's go back
to the story of the ugly duckling but
this time i'd like to play you a
recording made by a prisoner
because it encapsulates the power of
what we do
the prisoner was an irish traveler who
couldn't read
and he wanted to send a story home to
his daughter for her birthday
with the help of a mentor and some
clever editing
something magical happened
this is an extract from the raw
recording where the prisoner is reading
the story by repeating it
phrase at a time
[Music]
then one day he ran away
he ran until he came to the great marsh
he ran until he come to the great marsh
where the wild ducks lived
where the wild dogs lived
and this
is
a recording an excerpt of the recording
with the mentor's voice taken out
and sound effects and music added in
he had nowhere to ride
then one day he got away he ran until he
come to the great marsh where the wild
dogs lived and he laid in rushes for two
weeks
some wild dogs and geese come to look at
him you're very ugly they said and they
laughed at him
the ugly duckling ran away
from the great marsh
[Music]
and this is how he finished the story
he wasn't an ugly duckling at all during
the winter he had grown into a beautiful
white swan
the other swans has looked at him and
thought how beautiful he was
come with us they said and he did
[Music]
well tiara i hope you have enjoyed this
story
as much as i enjoyed reading this story
to you
i cannot wait to be with you again and
hold you in my arms
all my love your daddy owen
lots of love i miss you with all my
heart goodbye for now my life bye-bye
[Music]
when he listened to that recording in
his cell before it was sent out to his
daughter
he cried
and that's a pretty common reaction from
prisoners as they realize for the first
time they've been able to do something
for their child which they never thought
they could
they've connected in the most
fundamental way through the medium of
storytelling
and as for sophie
she wants the gruffalo next time
[Applause]
you